next question will republicans consider
biden illegitimate for four years yeah i
think that this is sort of a
good question to be asking the questions
about will biden really be sworn in
seem like a waste of time the questions
about can
donald trump really do this that that
that that you know all of these six
seven eight different things that he's
floated or others have floated as ways
to maybe steal the election we mentioned
some of them earlier
lawsuits or seizing voting machines
having governors send different electors
all
that's none of that stuff is going to
happen i think the right question is
how corrosive is donald trump insisting
on this stuff to democracy
and in particular the way in which
donald trump may be never conceding and
insisting he actually won
will affect the republican party
through joe biden's first two years and
four years
in the oval office now i think there's
two sides of it one is how will it
affect republican officials
and the second part is how will it
affect republican voters let's do voters
first because i think that one's really
easy
i think it's very clear at this point
that the combination of trump insisting
it was i mean just listen to the
voicemails i get people are convinced
trump insisting he really won
combined with newsmax and oan
and you know all the different the the
different hosts and
characters that have been insisting
trump actually won
that will leave a significant portion of
the
75 million who voted for trump believing
joe biden is an illegitimate president
for the duration of joe biden's
uh term there's no question about that
one is easy for me
the voters have been affected many
believe trump won
etc full stop the more interesting
question in terms of biden's governance
because
biden can't really do anything about
millions of republicans thinking he's an
illegitimate president the real question
is about biden's governance
and will republican elected officials
republicans in the senate
republicans in the house of
representatives and republican governors
around the country
will they uh in some way
resist working with biden in any way
specifically by
by failing him to recognize failing to
recognize him as a legitimate president
and i think it comes down to how visible
trump will be
after january 20th if we've already seen
more and more republicans just say biden
one
uh mitch mcconnell even congratulated
biden last week we covered that trump
was very triggered by it
if donald trump just sort of evaporates
politically fades away
on january 20th or before or slightly
after
i think you will see the vast majority
of republicans go back to dealing with
joe biden
the way they dealt with barack obama
which is there will be some who said
barack obama wasn't really
born here and isn't a legitimate
president but for the most part
they did the normal republican things
obstruct
pretend to be worried about the debt and
deficit call things government takeovers
anytime
the democratic president wants to do
something i think that's what you will
see
most republicans go back to now the
difference is
there are some really wacky uh congress
people elect
ready to be sworn in the house of
representatives um
in just days and i think that regardless
of what trump does
there's there's cueing on people who are
entering congress you know you have to
understand the
the impact of that i think they will
continue
to say they're absolutely wacky stuff uh
for
for the duration of their terms and
hopefully
they will be so ostracized by left and
right
that they will lose in 2022. that would
be the hope
it may not happen we may see more q anon
stuff in 2022. i just don't know
yet uh so that that's basically the lay
of the land i think that what trump has
done
has irreversibly um uh put
millions of his supporters in the
mindset that biden is not legitimate i'm
hearing from them in my voicemail every
single week
but the real question in terms of biden
for governance is how will republican
senators and members of congress
consider him and i think for the most
part they will see him as the legitimate
president